I made a big mistake another time flash
there are consequences to time travel
God's man grabbed forgiving
extraordinary abilities
greetings earthlings just kidding only
talks I listen to humor that's now
really something is an improvement in
this timeline I've kissed iris twice and
I have managed to erase both time from
existence
I hate when that happens guys my dream
let's train speedsters time I've got to
think anticipate what kind of hair are
you gonna be I'm just gonna take you
through all from every time to make a
mistake or live with them
we have always been my hero madness she
was the fastest man alive there's
nowhere he stopped us now there's one
person who can
the flash hey youtubers this charlie
new flash footage so we got Rogue Wars
stuff going on we have Jesse quake we
have dr. alchemy all kinds of villains
debuting in Episode two so so many
really big things being revealed in this
episode this is really like all the
stuff that they didn't have room for in
that first episode so we go back to
earth-2 we learned some of the
consequences of flashpoint the title of
the episode is paradox so you can see
how they're playing with the title
flashpoint paradox with the first two
episodes so we'll see how they weave the
idea of a paradox that set like a time
paradox into the episode itself because
typically paradoxes just create
contradictory situations things that
normally aren't supposed to exist so you
have speedster jessie quick looks like
they're rolling that out way faster
didn't expect her till episode three so
we get them back it looks like Barry
also goes to Jay Garrick's earth unless
some flashpoint twist brings him to
earth
it just seems like when he goes to other
Earth's they changed the way they filmed
the scenes like they make it look a
little bit dreamier so either way he's
talking to Jay Garrick Jay Garrick's
like dude are you gonna take a do-over
every time you do something that you
think is a mistake he basically tells
them he's a dumbass for flashpoint but
then we also see mirror master in top so
that's who these two characters are I
know it doesn't seem like you know
classic mirror master but he's going to
be the Sam Scudder version of the
character top is a man in the comics but
they gender flipped her we obviously see
dr. alchemy so there's this twist in the
comics whereby some of the Rogues were
working with dr. alchemy that's how I
think they accomplished that mirror
scratch in the first episode that was
mirror master scratching alchemy for dr.
alchemy so while the flash versus dr.
alchemy is gonna be like one of the big
things this year there's also this
internal rogue war that's going on
between mirror master and top and
Captain Cold in a bunch of other rows so
you basically have like a bunch of the
classic flash rogues that are split down
the middle and it looks like dr. alchemy
might be working with these two we also
see Cisco using his vibe powers to save
Barry from the rival so we know that
he's either the rival
already or he becomes the rifle in this
episode it just seems like dr. alchemy
is influencing a bunch of the villains
on the show in the interesting thing
about dr. alchemy it remains to be seen
how they changed the character from the
comics a lot of you know about the
Albert Desmond mister element who's kind
of like this split personality person
who by day is a totally normal scientist
but his split personality is the dr.
alchemy mister element personality the
villain so that might be what's going on
with Tom Felton's character because his
name on the TV show has been revealed as
Julian Albert not Julian Dorn
so I think they were using like part of
a fake name to throw you off a little
bit so Julian Albert Albert Desmond
mr. element so I think that's what's
going on with dr. alchemy this season so
he might be a split personality or he
might be a combination of a couple
different versions of the dr. alchemy
character Alpert Desmond was the first
one the second one was a different
person
his name was Alexander Petrov but he was
created by Geoff Johns and he's just the
next person to pick up the mantle after
Albert Desmond so like last year when we
got the big zoom reveal people were like
maybe zoom is like the alternate
personality of Jay Garrick like he has a
split personality and that's why when
he's walking around as Jay Garrick he
doesn't know about zoom but then they
went to hunter zolomon route so maybe
they are doing split personality in this
episode but that might be what we're
seeing here when we see Barry get
blasted with this blue lightning hear
him fighting dr. alchemy but there's
just a whole bunch of villains so I'll
try to explain who each of them are when
they debut like what they're doing with
the top character what they're doing
with the mirror master character so like
mirror master for instance a lot of you
know about the mirror world they said
they're not doing that this year
Mir master of the flash TV show at least
in season 3 will just be traveling
between mirrors they won't really be
doubling down on the spaces between the
mirrors just the idea that he travels
between reflective surfaces but the
other funny T's here is that Barry stops
the motorcycle with his finger here they
might be pushing deeper into the Sabbat
our plotline idea of people giving and
taking speed like Barry just complete
leeching the kinetic energy from the
bike it's just the whole idea behind
sabotage character is is that you can
siphon speed or you can control the
speed force itself instead of just
taking it the way they took it from
Barry last season but for those either
wondering there still seems to be
confusion about this this black flash is
called the rival he is not sabotage
sabotage is a completely different
character we don't know if they've cast
him yet or not it might be one of the
big secrets of the season like they
ripped the rivals masks off not gonna be
a big secret this season
so dr. alchemy wearing the mask with the
modulated voice who is Tobin Bell so
there's gonna be a lot of fun but
sabotage like the other big mystery so
savat are dr. alchemy big mysteries of
the season so let me know what you guys
are pumped for I know seeing Jesse quick
be a speedsters gonna be a lot of fun we
can't really tell what kind of costume
she's gonna be wearing because she's
wearing sweats here which is like hey
let's go workout but the torn jeans kind
of remind me of like her early 90s
designs but get height and there is a
new round of the flash giveaway all you
have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave a comment on this video
there's a whole bunch of dr. strange
Time gem footage so I'll probably do a
video for that next then I'll catch up
with Luke Cage there's a whole bunch of
other stuff
they started New York Comic Con and they
did a defender's Netflix and chill
session so I'll probably post that video
to Defenders Netflix and chill it's
gonna be awesome where you guys wait for
that to post you can click here for my
flash episode 1 video and you can click
here for my arrow episode 1 video thank
you so much for watching everybody let's
high five I'll see you guys tonight